permesso buongiorno bentrovati
buongiorno bentrovati è la mia prima
esperienza dedic sono grato di questa
bella compagnia tutti speaker molto
molto e così
insomma danno grande ispirazione quindi
ringrazio voi per essere qui oggi io
dico che siamo andati troppo avanti sono
andati troppo avanti siamo un po
stressati troppi macchinari troppa
tecnologia faccio il discorso al
contrario troppa tecnologia
[Musica]
io per esempio non riesco ad abituarmi
con le luci a sensori che tu entri in
bagno e si stai fermo poi si bloccano
tutto mentre sei in bagno deve
continuamente cercare soluzioni per non
stare al buio
l'altro giorno mi sono seduto in bagno
facevo questo non si riaccendevano a
loro ci sono spente io mi sono
addormentato e mi hanno preso con
l'ambulanza dopo due ore perché le gambe
non me le sentivo quindi la tecnologia
ci sta un po secondo me per certi
aspetti così chiamiamolo stressando io
mi occupo di teatro non mi occupo di
aziende mi occupo di altro quindi il mio
messaggio oggi rientra sulla sulla pausa
noi andiamo sempre molto veloci siamo
velocissimi siamo stressatissimi in
macchina ovunque col telefono anche nei
rapporti umani siamo sempre veloci pure
dio dopo il settimo giorno si riposa non
ce la faccio più uno basta mi fermo qua
va bene così in realtà noi corriamo
sempre però questo ci impone che a un
certo punto noi se capiamo facciamo una
pausa parlo di pausa perché siamo
bravissimi a correre ma a volte meno
bravi a fare le pause soprattutto in
teatro ma soprattutto nella
comunicazione noi con i nostri amici oi
nostri parenti soprattutto in sicilia
dobbiamo stare attenti nelle pause
perché una pausa vuol dire tanto vuol
dire vuol dire più di tante parole
quando sei a casa dalla mamma dalla
suocera e la mamma ti dice se vuoi un
altro piatto tu devi dire subito no
grazie
e chi se perdi tempo quel no grazie
arriva dopo lui un altro po di pasta
no grazie quel no grazie arrivato tardi
per cui tu c'hai la pasta nel piatto e
te la devi mangiare quindi queste pause
di senza attente a come controllarle non
è semplice oppure un amico che ti dice
guarda la foto di mia figlia oggi compie
18 anni e tu la guardi devi essere bravo
nel nei tempi perché tempi gestiscono
tutto nel nel comunicare se carina non è
carina perché se tu lo dici troppo
veloce a karina sì molto carina graziosa
bella sembra che non te ne frega niente
invece se tu perdi troppo tempo si
carina molto carina mi piace molto bella
troppo bella
già pare maniaco e allora il papa ti
toglie la foto serve un tempo meglio una
pausa i tempi sono essenziali
soprattutto in teatro
quando si parla di comunicazioni
capacità espressiva e noi riusciamo a
comunicare con diverse parti del nostro
corpo tra cui il corpo poi c'è la mimica
il gesto la voce e soprattutto le
intenzioni nelle intenzioni c'è tutto e
noi in ogni pausa di tutti questi canali
espressivi riusciamo inserire la nostra
la nostra pausa la pausa importante per
dare più forza quello che andremo a dire
dopo meno forza a quello che abbiamo
appena detto per cui la pausa richiama
l'attenzione succede anche bambini
quando la mamma vuole la mamma o la
maestra vuole richiamare l'attenzione
agli alunni a un certo punto si ferma e
bambini ci è successo è immediatamente
ai l'attenzione anche nel nelle poesie
non lo so noi riusciamo a declamare
poesie ma se non c'è la giusta pausa
perde valore tanto gentile e tanto
onesta pare la donna mia quand'è l'altro
esa mutac ogni lingua
de ven tremando muta e lottino l'hard
disk ogni guardare le pause teatralmente
vengono utilizzate per far arrivare il
messaggio per far arrivare così
l'intenzione dell'attore ma anche nei
rapporti con i nostri amici con i nostri
parenti insomma nei rapporti
interpersonali sono essenziali anche per
raccontare anche semplicemente una
battuta ma comunque per raccontare degli
aneddoti
io ricordo mio nonno quando un certo
punto gli chiedevo nonno ma tu hai fatto
la guerra se e chi ha vinto la nonna
quella pausa ci dà a tutti noi non è che
non diciamo niente nella pausa la pausa
ci da tutto mondo vi facciamo
permettiamo a chi ci ascolta di di farsi
un film di capire che cosa vuole
vogliamo dire realtà di quali messaggi
ci siano e mezzo è una cosa meravigliosa
l'altra volta io mi trovavo già solo con
la pausa riuscirà a far ridere solo con
la pausa non è facile ma anche lo
diciamo agli imprenditori alleggeriamo
le nostre tematiche riusciamo ad avere
un dialogo più leggero anche umoristico
così con un po di ironia io fa ridere
una pausa è una delle più grandi così
insomma aspirazioni di chi fa il mio
mestiere e me ne sono reso conto l'altra
volta ero in discoteca una ragazza
scollatissima si avvicina a me mi fa
secondo te questo vestito è troppo
scollato detto no si vedono solo un poco
i peli del petto ma io peli sul petto
non ne ho
allora è troppo scollato per cui in
realtà nelle pause nelle nostre
dinamiche verbali va bene conoscere il
tema va bene conosce il concetto sapere
tutto quello che c'è da dire ma in
realtà è bello giocare con i tempi con i
toni con i volumi perché noi le abbiamo
queste capacità capacità espressive al
di là del fatto di utilizzare per il
teatro per altre cose per lavoro però
nei rapporti noi sappiamo che ognuno di
questi canali espressivi ai suoi tempi e
i tempi sono la cosa più bella e più
esaltante della comunicazione non è solo
il contenuto il modo di esporre i
contenuti noi siciliani oltretutto
abbiamo una gestualità che già solo con
le mani
esprimiamo decine di concetti già solo
gu
con questo puoi dire decine di cose ma
kimi punti ma così ma che vuoi da me in
un gesto nello stesso gesto ci sono ci
sono tante cose nella forza con cui
viene fatto un gesto con cui viene fatta
una faccia con i tempi di reazione della
faccia noi riusciamo arricchire una
comunicazione fatta se non altro
comunque sono di contenuti e quindi
questo è meraviglioso nella nel rapporto
con gli altri rapporti di lavoro secondo
me noi a volte andiamo troppo veloci
troppo veloci più veloci facciamo in
dieci minuti facciamo 100 cose diverse
forse prima non avevamo tutti questi
mezzi strumenti quali alcuni insomma
vengono giustamente saltati perché ci
aiutano però prima avevamo meno ma forse
stavamo meglio perché avevamo il tempo
di alcune pause in più e non c'erano
certi strumenti e tu stavi più
tranquillo io mi ritrovo in autostrada
in certi momenti davanti a me c'è una
panda e non si vede neanche il guidatore
poi scopro che una signora 90 anni che
sta guidando a 60 persone che non siete
neanche la testa e va a 60 non perché a
90 anni ma perché c'è il cellulare in
mano
90 anni e non sta parlando sta scrivendo
a 90 anni tu in autostrada scrivi e che
scrivi non so se arrivo chi scrive
picchi non sei servitù non so se arriva
neanche io che ci andiamo ammazzare
tutti e due
bisogna stare attenti uno va sempre di
corsa la signora che guarda il cellulare
mette sotto un uomo con la macchia lo
mette sotto lo guarda guardi siamo
fortunati siamo di fronte al pronto
soccorso disgraziato io sono il dottore
del pronto soccorso signor per cui ti
rendi conto come noi abbiamo perso forse
delle pause facciamo delle pause siamo
veloci siamo preparatissimi siamo ci
sono tanti argomenti trattati dagli
speaker prima di me che sono di un
interessantissimo e soprattutto
riportano al centro l'uomo
l'uomo con i suoi tempi questo caso con
le sue pause perché secondo me non c'è
cosa più bella che dopo aver fatto tutto
fai una pausa vai a trovare lo zio e non
il cugino l'amico il vicino di casa una
persona anziana un bambino perdi tempo
che non è una perdita di tempo facendo
una pausa staccando pausa un sì nome è
sinonimo che interruzione fermati
fermati fai altro perché pausa non vuol
dire non fare niente vuol dire fare
altro
fai altro e vedrai che sarai rigenerato
perché non c'è cosa più bella che
fermarsi un attimo e prendersi una pausa
ora non so se voi siete d'accordo o meno
su quello che ho detto io però prima di
prendere la decisione
fate una pausa grazie
[Applauso]